hi I'm Chris Manning here to answer your
questions on artificial
[Music]
intelligence here are a couple of AI
generated
questions considering the rapid progress
in NLP what key factors and actions
should the community prioritize for a
responsible and ethical AI language
model deployment and development well
it's really good to know that the AI
systems are also thinking about what's
important for responsible and ethical AI
language model deployment so there are
lots of things to think about there we
certainly want systems that don't
exhibit conventional gender biases or
ethnic stereotypes the fact of the
matter is that all of the current large
language models do exhibit those
problems in part it's because these
models are just trained on a lot of
historical data from the world you know
one of the the things that human beings
are better at is having in their head
how they think the world should be
rather than just knowing how the world
has been and having statistics based on
that but there are also details of the
machine learning models where they tend
to emphasize majority cases and forget
about the minority cases so we should be
working out how to build models that do
a better job of that um but we should
also be trying to get data from
different sources so it represents
different groups and we should have the
preferences of different groups involved
in the evaluation of models finding
their weak spots teaching them how to
behave so a couple of people at Stanford
have been involved in this idea of jury
learning um Professor Michael Bernstein
and his students and the idea there is
that there isn't sort of one right
answer to how you should behave in many
contexts the different subgroups of
people have different um Impressions and
so you actually want to represent a jury
of your peers and how different people
feel about things and so lots of things
to explore in those
areas AI system asks what are some of
the most promising and exciting real
world applications of NLP that you
foresee emerging in the next few
years uh tons so I think we're going to
see a lot more NLP systems being
deployed
very successfully everywhere so a lot of
websites already have a little AI
assistant in the bottom corner I think
we're going to see a new generation of
ones powered by large language models
which really work much more fluently I
think we're going to see much more use
of conversational assistance so you're
thinking about um how to word an email
to your boss or you're not quite sure
what you should say to your boyfriend it
turns out that you can get advice
drafting help suggestions of what to say
um from a large language model that are
actually useful these days you know I
think there's just a whole world of ways
that we can use these models because our
world is so language based and that
we're all just sort of exploring what
some of the possibilities
[Music]
are